chili beef lettuce wraps cooking should
never be a chore the more you cook the
more confident you become that way you
actually start to enjoy it and that's
the key to good cooking had a bit of fun
along the way
this is minced beef and men support the
pork needs to sit in there otherwise the
beefs going to dry out really important
to season the mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot touch of olive oil
Vincent wakin up like that really helped
to sort of separate it so you can fry
off with a lot of color just food just
go through and start breaking that up
most important to remember his mince is
made up of cheap cuts brisket belly
short rib so it needs help and flying
off the mince for colour is so important
this pan what is hot your mince is gonna
boil or to hold the gray colour on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit tastes delicious and
seasoned deeply see how crispy is going
take it much further than you ever taken
minced before nice and crispy
smells incredible I'm training it is
crucial that keeps the mints nice and
crispy and you get rid of that excess
fat
[Music]
now let's wipe out the pan then wash it
low gasp now we're gonna add texture to
mince finely chopped chilli ginger
garlic and spring onions spring onions
give the sort of mince a really nice
freshness because it just gives that
crunch nicely thinly
now fly off the chilies the ginger the
garlic first sesame seed or teaspoon
only in garlic chili ginger in Y that
off nicely the sesame seed oil just
lifts up the whole flavor such a brown
sugar that starts to really caramelize
the chili the garlic and the ginger
mince in now my fish sauce like is it
the saltiness if you see now why it's so
important to get that minced really
crispy because nothing's going sogok
staying really crispy fresh lime
it makes the mince fragrant and then
lime juice roll it and squeeze out in
there
incredible a bit salty but the heat so
that the sweetness now got this sitting
this as well and then finally my spring
onions in right the last minute so I've
got crunch in there as well smells
amazing literally cooked the mince now
with sort of 30 seconds to go get off
and take it out
looks incredible smells so vital
to go with a chili beef I'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce
so everyone can dress the crispy mint to
their own taste
dipping sauce a teaspoon the brown sugar
soy sauce is a nice sort of dark rich
cover sesame seed oil a tablespoon and
just top that up with a tablespoon of
olive oil stops the sesame seed oil
becoming too rich a teaspoon of fish
sauce and then a touch of chili you
leave the seeds in again on the heat in
that sauce so impressive an amazing show
off centerpiece lime juice in McKoy
under chop it through once give that
little mix up check the seasoning mmm
that's lovely that's enriched now the
lettuce I'm gonna use baby Jan because
it's really nice and durable sort of
quite strong so you just sort of set
these nice trimmed lettuce leaves around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up spoon in you mince
and then little touch from dressing just
a little drizzle nice and that's the
secret of having good easy relaxed food
is that you just help yourself food that
looks and tastes a million bucks doesn't
have to be complex this dish is as fun
to cook as it is to eat
[Music]
take your fix and sort of place them in
gently coat white bait in the spicy
flower mix then fry